ein sprung aus dem fenster als letzter
ausweg aus diesem mehrfamilienhaus in
aschaffenburg sprangen eine mutter und
ihre zwei kinder aus dem zweiten stock
um den flammen zu entkommen
der brand in der wohnung so stark dass
eine flucht über das treppenhaus nicht
mehr möglich war
aufmerksame nachbarn erwiesen sich
jedoch als lebensretter legten matratzen
vor dem haus auf den boden sodass die 31
jährige und ihre fünf und 13 jahre alten
kinder aus dem fenster springen können
beim versuch die kinder aufzufangen
bracht sich ein 55-jähriger den arm
ein 47-jähriger mann drehte sich den
oberkörper die mutter verletzte sich bei
ihrem sprung schwer
es waren viele einsatzkräfte und der
artenschutz im gebäude
insgesamt habe es fünf verletzte
einige mit rauchgasintoxikation und drei
personen werden mit hubschraubern in
weiter weg liegende spezial
krankenhäuser geflogen
ein unglück mit erheblichem ausmaß mehr
als 80 rettungskräfte und drei
rettungshubschrauber kamen zum einsatz
die wohnung im zweiten obergeschoss ist
komplett ausgebrannt
teilweise
haben die flammen hoch bis zum dach
geschlagen das wird jetzt kontrolliert
das wurde strom und gas abgestellt und
sukzessive werden alle bereiche nochmal
kontrolliert warum sich das feuer in der
wohnung so schnell verbreitete ist noch
unklar
unglaubliche rettungsaktion tobi beier
ist vor ort und konnte mit einem der
räder sprechen stehe hier vor dem
wohnhaus in der obernauer straße in
aschaffenburg in dem ist eben gestern
brannte und nur durch den einsatz und
helden von mitbürgern der braun mit
ihrem fall kindern konnten diese
gerettet werden bevor in die gelegenheit
gehabt mit mehreren der retter zu
sprechen unter anderem eine gruppe von
fünf männern sie unterwegs war eine
rolle tour machen als sie hier wird in
ihrem west bank vor dem haus vorbeikam
und waren zwar ist irgendwie ein
bisschen sind stehengeblieben vor dem
haus geeilt und haben dann die
hilfeschreie der mutter gehört die hielt
schon ihr jüngstes kind aus dem fenster
ließ es dann fallen glücklicherweise in
dem moment als schon nachbarn herbei
geeilt waren mit einer matratze die die
helfer hochhielten um damit eben die
kinder nach und nach auch zu fangen erst
das kleine kind dann das größere hinter
größere junge der zudem noch
sehbehindert und geistig schwerbehindert
ist weil er sich nicht gut fortbewegen
kann deswegen anderen besonders
dramatisch dass die mutter den jungen
mann aus dem fenster werfen musste weil
er nicht selbst ausbilden konnte da er
eben nicht sehen konnte und zu guter
letzt noch schwer brandverletzten die
mutter die aus dem fenster sprang und
von den helden muss man sich glaube ich
wirklich nennen mit der matratze
aufgefangen wurden eine einmalige
geschichte die selbstlos war
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren